- Dude, have you seen
Making a Murderer yet?
- I was just about to ask you,
I binged it last night, it's incredible.
- So good, right?
- So good.
- Has anyone seen Ned?
- Last time I saw him, it was yesterday.
He was talking to Alaska.
(crunching)
- Someone has to find
out what happened to Ned.
(spooky violin music)
- [Ricky] He always had
a smile on his face.
You could really count on a guy like Ned
to just, like, brighten your day.
- He loved his job, he loved his wife.
- To think that someone
could do something like this
to a guy like that, makes my blood boil.
- The morning they brought
in Timothy Treadstone,
it just, it all started to make sense.
Of course it'd be him.
(guitar music)
- This ain't the first time
Alaska got himself in trouble.
- Alaska's the kind of guy that, yeah,
maybe had some shady parts in his past,
stealing people's lunches,
unplugging people's computers.
He ain't a saint, but that
don't make him a murderer.
I've seen Making A Murderer,
I think I'd know a murderer if I saw one.
- I know my roommate didn't do it.
- He was set up, so he
done got the best people
in the office to represent him.
- Ya know, they were the first one's
to finish Making A Murderer,
so they know it better than anyone.
(guitar music)
- How are you?
- I didn't see them plant the evidence,
no, but given all the misinformation
and outright slander
surrounding this employee,
plus my background in legal expertise
having watched Making A Murderer,
it wouldn't surprise me one bit
if there was corruption at work here.
- I promise nothing bad will happen to you
if you just say, "I shot Ned."
- I don't think I should do that.
- "I shot Ned," say it or I will hurt you.
- I shot Ned.
Why would you make me say that?
- So his coworkers had the motivation
to get him fired, and lo and behold,
you got this Try Guy, this golden goose,
just been out of thin air,
and who was the last person to see him?
Is, aha, Mr. Treadstone.
Sounds a lot like Making A Murderer to me.
- Has anyone actually
tried contacting Ned?
Like stopping by his house
or even giving him a call?
- I don't know.
(phone ringing)
- Hey, man, what's up?
- Ned?
You're alive?
Where are you?
- I'm at home, keep this between us,
but I finally started
watching Making A Murderer
and I'm taking a personal
day to finish it,
so good, am I right?
- That's not Ned.
- What do you mean?
- Would you ever pick up the
phone while binge-watching
an episode of Making A Murderer?
- Oh my god.
(spooky violin music)